und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend Außenministerin
berärburg ist erneut in den Nahen Osten
gereist unter anderem war sie heute im
Westjordanland und hat den
palästinensischen Ministerpräsidenten
getroffen reiste dann nach Tel Aviv
weiter welche Rolle Deutschland in
diesem Konflikt spielen kann ist nicht
klar zu umreißen Vermittlung wäre wohl
zu viel gesagt aber z ist die
Bundesregierung mit allen Seiten im
Gespräch der internationale Druck auf
Israel zumindest einer längeren
Waffenruhe zuzustimmen wächst die Angst
der Angehörigen um die Geiseln auch
Stefan leifert
berichtet in Tel Aviv haben sie heute
Abend eine Tafel für rund 240 Menschen
gedeckt eine Tafel deren Plätze leer
bleiben werden tausende sind auf den
Straßen um den Angehörigen der Geisel
en Sil wenkert bangt um ihren Enkel Omer
seine Freundin erschossen er von der
Hamers entführt ich habe überlebt im
Holocaust ich bin schon eine alte Frau
aber jetzt ist der richtige Holocaust
für mich damals war ich ein kleines Kind
fast ein
Baby aber jetzt diese 5
Wochen ist nicht zum beschreiben was wir
leiden ganze Familie weil wir wissen
nichts von
ihm während Israel sein Trauma bewältigt
setzt seine Armee die Angriffe auf Gaza
fort die Dunkelheit der Nacht zeigt
besonders klar wie heftig der Beschuss
im Moment ist hier Bilder aus der Nacht
zu Samstag aufgenommen von israelischer
Seite das Vorgehen der Armee
konzentriert sich heute auf das
alschifer Krankenhaus das größte in Gaza
unter dem Gebäude soll die Hamas ein
Kommandozentrum betreiben
das hier ist mehr Kampfzone als
Krankenhaus es ist eine gespenstische
Atmosphäre die Bombardierungen dauern
nun seit über 24 Stunden ohne
Unterbrechung an vom Boden und aus der
Luft laut israelischeem Militär haben
150.000 Menschen den Norden des
gaserstreifens verlassen kurze und
lokale Feuerpausen machen das möglich
auf dem Gelände des Krankenhauses Reihen
die die noch da sind die Toten
aneinander hört Land und Soldaten immer
wieder auf einen harten Kampf ein israel
habe keine Alternative zum Sieg über
Hamas ich rufe dazu auf dass unsere
entführten zurückkommen ich weise die
Forderung nach Feuerpausen zurück die
nicht zur Freilassung unserer Geiseln
führen die israelische Armee
veröffentlicht heute diese Bilder aus
Gaza spricht von Fortschritten im Kampf
gegen die Infrastruktur der Hamas wie
hier eine Zeit nach dem Krieg aussehen
soll macht die internationale Politik
noch ratlos auf ihr ostreise formuliert
die deutsche Außenministerin Bedingungen
es ist ganz klar Hamas muss bekämpft
werden aus dem Gazastreifen darf keine
Terrorgefahr mehr für Israel
ausgehen es darf aber auch keine
Vertreibung aus Gaza keine Besatzung
oder territoriale Reduzierung von Gaza
geben auf telavivs Straßen spielt die
Zukunft noch keine große Rolle zu groß
ist noch das Trauma der Gegenwart
zugleich reisten heute die Potentaten
der muslimischen Welt nach Riad das
saudische Königshaus hatte zu einem
außerordentlichen Gipfel geladen zu den
angereisten gehörte auch der Präsident
der iranischen Republik ein relativ
spektakulärer Gast bei den Saudis das
wäre bis vor kurzem nicht möglich
gewesen und auch Syriens Diktator Assad
gab sich die Ehre der Mann der mehr
arabische Muslime im eigenen Land töten
ließ als jeder andere in der Region
nicht zu vergessen zahlreiche
Palästinenser deren Stadtviertel in
Damaskus er aushungern und bombardieren
ließ als sich dort dihadisten
festsetzten große protestdemos gegen
diese Kriegsverbrechen hat man damals in
Europa allerdings nicht gesehen vom
Verlauf des Treffens heute in Riad
berichtet guline
Atal von Riad soll ein Signal der
Einheit ausgehen mit dabei mehr als 50
staatschifs sowohl usverbündete wie
Jordaniens König Abdallah als auch
iranhürige wie syriens Machthaber Basar
al-Assad ein historischer Moment
erstmals geben sich ehemals politische
Feinde die Hand iranspräsident raisi und
der saudische Kronprinz bin
Salman so viele Differenzen auf einen
Nenner zu bringen ist ein schier
unmögliches Unterfangen doch der Schärfe
des Gastgebers schließen sich viele hier
an der saudische Kronprinz verurteilt
den so wirklich barbarischen Krieg und
erfdert einen sofortigen echten
Waffenstillstand wir erleben eine
humanitäre Katastrophe sie zeigt sich im
Scheitern des un Sicherheitsrates und
der internationalen Gemeinschaft die
ungeheuerlichen Verstöße Israels gegen
das Völkerrecht zu
beenden viele eint die Sorge vor einem
neuen Extremismus wenn der Krieg
weitergehe
unsere Region wird sonst einen großen
Konflikt erleben den Preis dafür werden
unschuldige auf beiden Seiten zahlen und
die Folgen werden die ganze Welt
erreichen andere wie irans Präsident
profitieren von der gegenwärtigen
Anspannung und treiben sie weiter an
gehe der Krieg weiter verlangt er gar
Waffenlieferungen für die
Palästinenser
wir fordern zudem den Abbruch aller
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen mit dem zionistischen Regime
und einen Handels und
energiebikott syriens Machthaber bekannt
für seine Verbrechen gegen Zivilisten
nun aber solidarisch mit Palästinensern
in Gaza schlägt in die gleiche Kerbe wie
die Islamische
Republik jede politische jede
wirtschaftliche Annäherung mit der
zionistischen Entität muss erst einmal
gestoppt
wer doch damit bleiben Iran und Syrien
allein weder Saudi-Arabien noch die
Emirate Folgen solchen
extremforderungen am Ende verkündet der
saudische Außenminister nur eine
minimale Einigung eine Kerngruppe soll
politischen Druck erzeugen um weitere
Waffenlieferungen an Israel zu
verhindern und die zwei staatenlösung
voranzutreiben fragen wir doch noch mal
nach bei gulin ATI das war ja schon
interessant zu sehen wer da heute alles
zusammen kam bei diesem Gipfel was eint
die denn also wo liegt das gemeinsame
Interesse in diesem aktuellen
Konflikt nun die Bilder täuschen darüber
hinweg dass es mehr Verschiedenheiten
gibt den Gemeinsamkeiten denn im
Hintergrund wurde man sich nicht einig
auf ein
Abschlussdokument es gab zahlreiche
Staaten die auf extreme Forderungen
gedrängt haben wie z.B keine
überflugsrechte für israelische
Flugzeuge oder aber
energieboukotte oder aber Abbruch aller
Beziehungen zu Israel und diese Staaten
konnten sich nicht durchsetzen die
Emirate z.B die haben Beziehungen zu
Israel und die sind im Moment nicht
bereit diese Beziehungen aufzukündigen
saudi-Arabien hat als oberste Priorität
erst einmal Ruhe und Stabilität um das
eigene Land zu entwickeln
das geht wirklich allem vor deswegen let
man hier auch ehemalige Feinde ein
lächelt ihnen zu und hält sie sich stets
eine Armlänge entfernt es ist nicht so
dass die Emirate das Ägypten
Saudi-Arabien die Hamas mögen ganz und
gar nicht aber tatsächlich gibt es eine
ernsthafte Verärgerung bei diesen
Regierungen über westliche
Doppelstandards in Sachen Völkerrecht
und man muss auch solche Konferenzen
solche Bilder und Statements
produzieren weil man der eigenen
Bevölkerung etwas zeigen muss um dem
Druck der Straße soz sagen zu
vorzukommen danke schön
g wie gesagt als Assad das
palästinensische flüchtlingsviertel
jarmuk aushungerte und zerbombte blieb
die arabische Welt stumm europäische
proalästinensergruppen übrigens auch und
damit geht's jetzt bei dir weiter Heinz
in mehreren deutschen Städten hat es
heute wieder proalästinensische
Demonstrationen gegeben in Berlin
München oder wie hier in Wuppertal won
Naach Polizeiangaben etwa 000 Menschen
zusammenkamen die Veranstaltung sei
insgesamt überwiegend friedlich
verlaufen eine proalästinensische
Demonstration mit mehreren hunderttaus
Teilnehmern fand in London statt nach
Schätzungen der Polizei beteiligten sich
mehr als 300 000 Menschen an dem
Demonstrationszug durch die Innenstadt
ebenfalls heute in London Gedenken an
die weltkriegstoten am Jahrestag des
Waffenstillstands im Ersten Weltkrieg
russland hat die Ukraine nach Angaben
aus Kiev erneut mit zahlreichen Drohnen
und Raketen angegriffen der Großteil
wurde laut Flugabwehr zerstört aus Kiev
wurde der Einschlag von zwei besonders
schwer vom Radar zu erfassend den
Raketen auf einem Feld gemeldet mehrere
Häuser seien durch die Druckquelle
beschädigt worden besonders um kämpft
ist nach wie vor aufjwka im Gebiet danjk
Polizisten fordern die verbliebenen
Bewohner auf sich in sich Sicherheit zu
bringen die Stadt liegt Laub
Militärverwaltung rund um die Uhr unter
Beschuss Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing
plädiert dafür die Strafen für das
Eindringen in Sicherheitsbereiche von
Flughäfen zu verschärfen und erforderte
gegenüber den funkemedien die
Flughafenbetreiber auf ihre
Sicherheitskonzepte zu überprüfen eine
Reaktion auch auf das Geiseldrama am
Hamburger Flughafen vor einer Woche ein
Mann hatte mit einem Auto die
zufahrtsbeschränkung durchbrauch und war
auf das Vorfeld
gelangt wer eine wirklich spektakuläre
und exotische Landschaft sehen will muss
gar nicht in weite Fernen Reisen Island
bietet Vulkane Gletscher dampfende
geisiere eine blaue Lagune whalewing und
dann laufen da auch noch überall
entzückende kleine Pferde mit wilden
wuschelmähen und Knopfaugen herum die
traurig gucken wenn man sie als Ponys
bezeichnet kurz um eine faszinierende
Insel die von ihren Bewohnern natürlich
heiß und innig geliebt wird die Isländer
wissen aber dass ihre Natur nicht nur
schön sondern auch gefährlich ist und
bekommen das derzeit wieder heftig zu
spüren da braut sich was gewaltiges
zusammen auf Island berichtet
besche mitten im Interview wackelt die
Welt von Fan Friedrichson Bürgermeister
von grinderweg es bebt hier in seinem
4000 Seelendorf im Südwesten Island so
sehr dass es vergangene Nacht
vorsorglich evakuiert wird durchschlafen
kann ja ohnehin niemand mehr seit zwei
Wochen tausende von kleinen Erdbeben was
unter grinderweg los ist zeigt sich
oberhalb Risse Gräben meterbreite
Spalten mir sind die Sachen aus dem
Regal geknallt ich rantete nur noch im
Kreis um irgendwie alles
festzuhalten heute ist grinderwieg eine
Geisterstadt denn die Sorge dass hier
oder in unmittelbarer Nähe ein Vulkan
ausbricht steigt stetig
die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht sich
gestern hätte ich auf 6040 getippt heute
sind wir eher bei 75 25 Island ist aus
Vulkanen geboren auch die vergangenen
zwei Jahre hat es mehrere Ausbrüche
gegeben Touristen aus aller Welt kamen
um sich an diesen Bildern zu
berauschen doch augenblicklich liegen
mehr Sorgen über der Vulkaninsel denn es
könnte eine für isländische Verhältnisse
besiedelte Region treffen das
Geothermiekraftwerk das den
Hauptflughafen kefflerwig versorgt die
Blaue Lagune das bei Touristen beliebte
Thermalbad es wurde vorsorglich schon
geschlossen die Blaue Lagune das könnte
sehr unangenehm werden da könnte es zu
Dampf oder Gasexplosionen kommen und das
würde dann eine Menge Wasserdampf auch
erzeugen der würde sich mit Gasen aus
der aus der Lava vermischen und das
könnte auch ein bisschen gefährlich
werden dass es noch mal so kommt wie
2010 als der E F jökel ausbrach und den
Flugverkehr in Europa lahm legte halten
Experten für ausgeschlossen trotzdem
weiß keiner was kommt der isländische
Präsident ruft zur Einheit auf Island
ist ein kleines Land wir können unsere
Kleinheit in stärker verwandeln manchmal
sind wir wie eine kleine
Familie mancher in den Evakuierten Dorf
grinderwieg nimmt es ohnehin stoisch
Isländisch niemand zu Hause wir machen
vulkanurlaub heute am 11.11 hat die
bekanntlich fünfte Jahreszeit begonnen
besonders wurde das in den Karnevals
Hochburgen entlang des Rins gefeiert in
Köln sind pünktlich um 11:11 Uhr
Tausende jcken in die Session gestartet
und auch in Mainz feierten viele
narrinnen und Narren rund um den
fassnachtsbronnen und jetzt die
Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne Gewehr 9 25 26 40 45 49
Superzahl 7 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 die Wetteraussichten für morgen von
Südwesten her dichte Wolken mit Regen
oberhalb etwa 800 m anfangs auch Schnee
im Nordosten bewölkt und Schauer sonst
länger freundlich mit Sonne 4 bis 10°
die weiteren Aussichten in den nächsten
Tagen sehr wechselhaft und teilweise
stürmisch vor allem am Alpenrand
ergiebiger Dauerregen dazu sehr mild bei
6 bis
15° das war's von uns mit dem Aktuellen
Sportstudio geht's gleich weiter und
danach gibt's gegen 025 Uhr die nächste
heute Express bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen